artists choose a role because they can
inhabit the character and make it their
own these five superb actresses have
done more than just that they created
some of the best moments of the year on
film the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role are sure a
aghdashloo in House of Sand and Fog
Patricia Clarkson in pieces of April
Marcia Gay Harden in Mystic River
Holly Hunter in 13 Renee Zellweger in
Cold Mountain
and the Oscar goes to Renee Zellweger
and hum Mountain
this is Renee Zellweger's first Academy
Award she was nominated the last two
years in the lead actress category for
Bridget Jones's Diary and Chicago
I am overwhelmed I am overwhelmed thank
you um I would like to thank the Academy
for inviting me here tonight
um alongside so many talented people
Holly
Patricia Marsha and I'm sure a I am
honored honored to be here with you um
I'm standing here because of so many
people and I would like to thank them
now if I could Charles Fraser um thank
you for your masterpiece and the the
gift of Ruby I have to thank the
producers cast and crew of cold mountain
I'll never forget it
never because of you especially dude and
Nicole such a privilege to go to work
every day with you such privilege my
friends thank you
Anthony Minghella you are brilliant and
I care so much for you thank you for all
that you taught me for making me be
better and for your friendship
my friends at Miramax for making this
film especially Harvey and um and in
Mariposa quite a gamble thank you for
doing it my fellows at CAA Brant and
Brian and Kevin and Jenny Rawlings who
take such good care of me
actors Clearinghouse for the good start
some Delson it's an off Rio for teaching
me how to work Tom Cruise for showing me
that very early on kindness and success
are not mutually exclusive and finally
most importantly in my life my glorious
family um my immigrant mom and dad thank
you for never saying don't try my
brother who I love so much and his new
wife who clapped the loudest and laugh
the loudest I love you so much Nancy
Ryder who's always there and my beloved
John Carradine oh thank you for sharing
this journey with me every day of it
without you there would be none of this
thank you for dreaming so much bigger
than I would ever dare to dream and for
making me believe I love you it's for
you
you